Who ordered the double cheese and sausage?
Right here, dude.
How do you get your pizza delivered?
Last month, Domino's Pizza teamed up with a creative ad agency titled T + Biscuits...
...to test down a prototype for a flying drone that can deliver cheese pies.
Described as an octocopter, the device carried two large pepperoni pizzas...
...and conducted a flight over a city near London.
The pizzas, both contained in an insulated bag, were secured to the drone.
They were delivered in perfect condition...
...and it only took about ten minutes to venture four miles.
The founder of T + Biscuits stated, "If anything it went quicker than a pizza boy,..."
"...we were amazed at how easy it was going to be."
The drone is being called the DomiCopter.
Although the device won't take the place of human delivery drivers anytime soon,...
...Domino's is reportedly experimenting with the drone at their UK headquarters.
Federal Aviation Administration authorities estimate...
...that private drones will make up a 90-billion-dollar industry within ten years.